what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro back at it again to discuss
the latest developments in the borto
story and also to go over some
mind-blowing news about the boruto manga
that could change
everything if you do enjoy seeing naruto
and boruto videos on this channel and
want to keep them coming the best thing
you can do is smash that like button and
share this video if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select all or
you will miss future naruto and boruto
videos
so if you haven't make this the day you
subscribe
and as you wait for the next boruto
chapter or video to drop feel free to
check out my growing naruto
boruto playlist where i got videos about
the hokage all ototsuki
all uzumaki and most recently all
akatsuki members
and their powers explained links to that
playlist and the new akatsuki video can
be found in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all first i want to
cover and give my thoughts on the
absolutely mind-blowing news that
masashi kishimoto
is returning to write the rest of the
boruto series so if you don't know
up until now ukyo kodachi was handling
the writing and storyboarding for boruto
while artist
mikio ikemoto was handling the drawings
in a tweet kodachi wrote that the baton
of borto has finally been returned to
kishimoto sensei
and ikemoto sensei please give your warm
support to boruto on his journey from
henceforth as well
i will be looking forward to it together
with our readers from now on end quote
so from the sounds of it the look and
character designs of the manga will stay
the same
but the original naruto creator is going
to be coming up with the story himself
rather than just supervising it chapter
52 of the manga will be released
tomorrow november
20th 2020 and will reportedly be working
off of kishimoto's original drafts
keep in mind that the difference may not
seem big at all in the beginning since
kishimoto
has to finish up the arc from where
kadachi stopped
but in the long run you can bet this is
going to have a significant shift
and i for one am very excited by this i
got nothing against kodachi
and i think he was doing a great job
with the boruto manga i
very much enjoyed it but at the same
time it's kishimoto's writing that i
first fell in love with
as a 12 year old kid when my friend let
me borrow a naruto manga
for a silent reading period in school it
was about the tuning exams and i got
completely hooked on it
naruto is the first manga i ever bought
so yes my nostalgia may be coming
through hard right now
but i can't think of better news than
kishimoto the original creator
coming back to finish the sequel of the
series i loved so much
once again nothing against kodachi he
worked on some of my favorite series
including code geass but i strongly
believe that the world of naruto and by
extension
boruto is best served by kishimoto
himself
let me know what you guys think in the
comments and there's been plenty of
funny memes about sadada's character
development going completely down the
drain
but i'm personally optimistic overall
with everyone talking about decreasing
manga sales for boruto getting the
naruto creator on board like this
could really make a difference after all
under kishimoto naruto became one of the
best selling manga of all time
and is currently the fourth top selling
manga series ever
the interest for naruto clearly hasn't
gone away but some people felt like
boruto was not worth watching
a because the anime fillers made them
assume the manga was bad
and b because it didn't feel that
official since kishimoto
wasn't playing a major role in it
hopefully with kishimoto
back in a major role producing the story
himself we'll get more people willing to
give the borto manga a shot
and if that happens we're likely to have
more boruto
and we'll keep getting to see our
favorite characters like naruto
that i've personally known for over half
of my life and that brings us to the new
chapter chapter 52. remember we left off
at chapter 51 where kurama pretty much
said naruto was gonna die if he used
this new form
and arto was like yeah let's use it so
we got the new form but apparently at
the cost of naruto's life
and it's kind of funny how as soon as
naruto was supposed to die they're like
kishimoto is taking over
i know it's probably just a coincidence
but it makes more sense that someone who
didn't come up with naruto would be more
okay with killing him off
so his main protagonist can shine but
with kishimoto back in the driver's seat
even if naruto's death was a possibility
before
which it probably wasn't but even if it
was it probably isn't now
i don't think kishimoto would be down to
kill off naruto and that would be a
terrible move for sales too
because a lot of people just read boruto
for more naruto and naruto's new form
pretty much eclipsed
anything boruto did in recent memory in
terms of the hype so yeah i think our
boy naruto is in good hands
but let's head on to the spoilers and
remember to take these with a grain of
salt i'll come out with another video
where we have the official translations
but i thought it would be fun to see
what we could learn from these
unofficial spoilers
so the chapter is called baryon mode and
we get a clear
image of naruto's new form in the cover
and it looks awesome
new forms can be hit or miss in terms of
design but i like the way they handled
this one
in the chapter kurama describes the new
form as nuclear fusion
like the sun releasing its energy it's
about using my chakra and your chakra to
create new energy end quote
and i like the fact that they even
brought the sun into it because in my
recent video explaining naruto's new
form i did mention that the mode
reminded me of esquinor escondors the
one ultimate mode so this seems to be
quite fitting
but back to the spoiler conversation
between kurama and naruto
naruto asks how it is different from the
nine tails mode
and the six paths mode and kurima
mentions that it's fundamentally
different
and he restates the same thing in a
different way saying that before
they were using chakra from other places
and this time they are using each of
their chakras as raw materials to create
new energy and kurama emphasizes the
fact that they shouldn't make
unnecessary movements
because they want the new form to last
as long as possible and to be used to
its fullest
this naruto as i guessed and probably
most of us did
was nothing like the one before i was
mentioning that he'd ridiculously
surpass
sasuke's level if he could hold his own
against ishiki
when sasuke and old naruto couldn't even
do that working together
and sure enough when the fight begins
naruto is more than holding his own
we're told he overwhelms ishiki in the
beginning and dodges some shots
when ishiki tries to bury him under
blocks naruto manages to easily lift
them
while sasuke is simply trying to take
boruto away from the battlefield
ishiki responds that it's impossible
that naruto could manage such a sudden
surge of power
building up the hype even more so we
leave off with naruto's new form holding
its own at the very least
and we jump to kawaki and a motto
through the prosthetic arm that naruto
gave him kawaki realizes that naruto is
getting weaker
the new deadly form is clearly taking
its toll and we move back to naruto so
even though for a time
naruto was doing more than well now he's
physically exhausted he drops to one
knee
and the pattern on his new form is
disappearing burto gets worried but
feints from pain we're told
ishiki mentions that the enhanced
ability of naruto summoned is a great
killing ability but he will only win
if he sacrifices his life so i look
forward to the official translations
here because
from this it seems like ishiki is saying
naruto could definitely win
if he chose to sacrifice his life but
then ishiki laughs at naruto for losing
which is a bit weird
we know naruto is ready to sacrifice his
life to win
so why would ishiki be happy if naruto
would win by sacrificing his life
again this will probably make more sense
with the official translations
then just as ishiki is being cocky he
vomits blood and becomes shaky
ishiki is shocked wondering what
happened saying that naruto's attack
should not have been fatal
and naruto then seems to say who were
you saying is going to die
end quote implying that it's going to be
ishiki and then he says the real battle
starts now which is hella hype
and kurama says what i expected inside
naruto he mentions that the power is
definitely above ishiki
but they still can't beat him because
the side effects are so great that
they'll be the first to die compared to
ishiki
so this form seems to even surpass
reincarnated ishiki
but not enough to kill him before its
time runs out
and for ishiki he too is quickly running
out of time
he thought he had 20 hours left but now
it seems he only has 30 minutes left i
also predicted in my video about how
straw naruto's new form is
that naruto would push ishiki enough so
that he'd exhaust a lot of his remaining
energy
and that seems to be the only
explanation for ishiki's significantly
lower time limit
then kurama tells naruto to not think
about hitting ishiki
but to just think of hitting him with
every single and real
blow like boxing this is another
instance where i look forward to seeing
the official translation
but i'm guessing he means not to waste a
punch or kick that doesn't count
hold off until you know you'll cause
some real damage so as not to waste
unnecessary
energy and i do appreciate the boxing
analogy
shout out to hajime noipo while sasuke
can only watch and comment on naruto's
rapidly decreasing chakra borto is still
unconscious
ishiki actually manages to get naruto by
the neck
and then he feels kawaki's chakra and
laughs
ishiki says that he is the winner we
jump to kawaki who is taken through a
portal and everyone is left dumbfounded
and it seems that ishiki was able to use
the connection of naruto's arm on kawaki
to make a connection and bring him there
and so in the last minute
he can leave his karma on kawaki and so
this is a victory for him
then as if that wasn't crazy enough
apparently boruto's ipower drogon
activates
and that is the end of this chapter what
a freaking chapter for kishimoto to
return for
we got to see the new format work it was
surpassing ishiki for a time but ishiki
managed to last long enough to gain the
upper hand again
and even bring kawaki to him and boruto
awakened the drogon in the manga and
i've really been waiting for that
we got to see naruto shine and burtoshan
at the same time and this is arguably
gonna be the best chapter boruto yet
again we gotta take these translations
with a grain of salt but if the official
is
anything like this i feel like this
could be possibly the best chapter of
borto yet
anyways let me know what you thought of
these leaks and how you feel having the
original crater back in the driver's
seat
again i'm so glad myself because naruto
is my first manga and it will always
hold a special place in my heart so to
have the creator returning like this
is absolutely amazing if you did enjoy
this video and want to keep the naruto
slash boruto videos coming
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know and share this video with
any fellow naruto fans
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto slash porto videos
so if you haven't make this the day you
subscribe and as you wait for the next
porto chapter or videos to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
porto playlist where i got videos about
the hokage all otutsuki
all uzumaki and most recently all
akatsuki members and their powers
explained
links to the playlist and to the new
akatsuki video can be found in the
description
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you